uh we're gonna begin this hour uh with
an environmental story the uh grip of
drought that is intensifying in the west
has led scientists to turn to an unusual
ally in the fight to limit the effects
of climate change we're talking about
the largest rodent in north america the
beaver our earth 365 series focuses on
issues affecting the health of our
planet year round and our jonathan
bigliotti got to see firsthand how
scientists in california and utah are
using beavers to help create landscapes
resistant to drought and fire
in the drought-stricken american west an
animal long considered a pest
is now in demand
beavers are largely nocturnal animals
meaning they're most active at night
it's very rare to see them so close
you ready to go yeah
okay let's do it we hiked down a rugged
hillside with scientists he's a heavy
guy
and a 90 pound trapped beaver to take
him to his new home
what we're hoping for is a place with
deep water our hope is that they start
building dams it's the latest chapter
for a species that's been desired and
despised
for centuries the nation's largest
rodent was a fashion staple that's new
and hats for winter coveted for its fur
and of course the old reliable beaver
they were nearly hunted to extinction by
1900 until they went out of style and
the mammal's population rebounded but
soon they became a headache for
landowners who didn't appreciate the
flooding their dams caused they were
trapped and killed the lucky ones were
relocated flown and parachuted into
remote terrain and the most unusual and
novel trip ends for mr beaver
but as mega wildfires fueled by climate
change have ripped through the west
researchers made an incredible discovery
in the ashes
a beaver dam created an oasis that
survived the flames
scientist emily fairfax couldn't believe
her eyes and i was like this is unreal
like does this happen everywhere where
are we right now we are just downstream
of the main beaver dam which is holding
back an absolutely enormous volume of
water so without the beaver dam in this
area
what would this be like right now this
would be bone dry and sandy which is
what it was before the beavers moved in
as fairfax showed in an animation she
created when beavers build dams they
prevent rainwater and snowmelt from
draining down rivers and into oceans the
result is a natural fire break and
reservoir capable of storing water for
years and releasing it slowly over time
this 10 foot tall beaver dam a web of
sticks and mud in a tuscadero california
created the only lush landscape for
miles beavers move in here and they slow
this water down a lot of it does go into
recharging the groundwater and that's
what we're pumping for irrigation that's
what we use for our food that's what we
use for our lawns a lot of the water in
california is not from snowmelt it's
from the groundwater and these beavers
are recharging it for us so they're sort
of depositing water into the bank that
we take out at a later date the west's
historic drought and fairfax's research
has led to a reckoning for farmers and
landowners beavers can be good
but with so many of them removed from
the landscape
reintroducing them now requires help
from humans we're here in utah just
outside of salt lake city
and this morning we're building a beaver
dam volunteers are now building starter
dams what's known in the industry as
beaver dam analogs the owner of this
ranch heard about the new program and
wanted in nick baus is a lead on the
project
why do beavers need human help to build
a dam
well a lot of times if it's too shallow
they're just kind of like
walking hot dogs for predators they need
deep water to swim they're very graceful
in deeper water
so beavers that they do
is they get in
here and they just scoop the mud up
they just come and
like grab a whole bunch push it with
their chests and hands and they just
work it in all the crevices this is very
similar to what a beaver would naturally
do
i would
get on my belly and uh
push it in but i don't want to get that
wet it's amazing all the steps that
we have to do
to help out something that should be a
natural process
but the most challenging step is finding
the right candidates for release
that's where nate norman with utah state
university comes in he traps beavers
from land where they're considered
nuisances then takes them back to this
beaver lab where he weighs them
checks them for injuries real minor
little knots
chips them for tracking and research and
then places them in what he calls a
beaver bunker where they wait until
their permanent home the one we've been
prepping
is ready
which brings us back to where we began
on this day we're releasing two beavers
the hope is
they'll soon start a colony of their own
more than a thousand analog dams have
been successfully resettled with more in
the works it's kind of a win-win you
know we deal with the nuisance problem
at the same time trying to use
a animal that's incredibly good at
restoring streams but putting them to
work the north american beaver once just
a pest
now
a climate change engineer for cbs
mornings jonathan vigliotti coleville
utah
well bigly audi looked good in that
black t-shirt and the wigs i wouldn't
say it looked great but when that beaver
came out of the cage and took a look at
the damn that jonathan helped build i
don't think they were pumping i got me
going back in dirty water yeah shout out
to the beavers though yeah i know who
knew viggs out there putting in work
that's his hasselhoff moment right
that's a lot of work wow shout out to
vixx oh